all right are you guys ready i've been
practicing this song for the last 15
minutes in preparation for this podcast
okay whoever guesses whoever guesses it
first wins i don't know what you win yet
um
i know what it is
[Music]
stacy's mom
no no no no no no i hear it now
[Music]
enter sandman oh all night long
yeah let's go i was close
wow
it's between them stacy's mama's a real
toss-up
it's beautiful
hey what's on the docket this week
good question woo welcome back to the
next quarter cast episode 128.
we've got jordan allen in the house
sam gorski
what's up brandon wyckman
what's up
and uh of course me jake watson i know
you guys are getting sick of me but here
i am back again well don't worry we have
a plan for that
oh my god is it how much has it
developed since this morning well it's
not done yet but can we talk about it i
mean the video where i mean like we just
started filming
it's not really a secret this isn't
going to be like a secret
live stream kind of thing that nico did
uh yeah
but you know we're all the only people
we're going to try to fool here are
today's sponsors
yeah today's sponsors are probably the
only people who will get fooled
but nico's doing the face
deep fakes obviously for many many years
now um but sam you have a big background
in audio yes so i'm like hey let's do ai
voices and
i've been messing with it for a while
for a few months but like everything's
kind of crappy like i don't know the
whole python scripting stuff that you
know
i think
you know that's what would really make
it awesome but
i
found the next best thing which was
for a mere 30 dollars i can have someone
else do all the work for me
so i'm using a service to recreate some
ai voices right now and
it's very promising
it's very very very pretty i literally
came in this morning
and you and peter were already like
experimenting with this and i was like
just dropped into like what you had
going and you had already trained this
model with your voice and then he was
able to basically type in some text and
his voice read it from the computer and
it was slightly robotic not very it
still sounded pretty good
but the best part in my opinion was when
you started throwing in like tongue
twisters and you were just like nailing
it yeah
tongue twisters yes it's weird it's like
the fidelity is very good and it sounds
very realistic the only thing that's not
realistic right now is
the
just that you know it's just that vocal
dynamic yeah intonation
performance
so um yeah that was a little off but
hopefully with these updated changes
basically so you it's uh you're
basically like just like a deep fake
you take a data set so for a deep fake
you take a ton of pictures of faces
and then for the audio data set you're
basically just doing tons of dialogue so
i come down here to the audio room
flip on the mic i gave it like a 15
minute data set of me
reading from a book just 15 minutes
straight
and then uh they gave us the base level
i guess foundation but what i didn't do
was i didn't like
i didn't do a huge performance in it you
know i wasn't like
getting emotional i wasn't getting like
i wasn't like showing happiness or anger
or whatever you know and so the data set
is basically just me in a pretty calm
narration tone
but what i did just today was gave it
another 15 minutes
and it's broken up into like a couple
chunks of different emotional states
which then i can go
later and say hey okay after you've gone
through this data set i can select
those portions of the audio
and create like voice styles so that way
hey as here's a really weird id hold on
oh you keep talking my uh headphones
i'll just get new ones i can hear you
okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna hold this thought
then until sam gets back because
this could be really weird
should we you could play uh stacy's mom
again while we wait i know okay
stacy's mom yeah we might want to just
cut this bit from the actual finals no
we don't cut anything anymore and we're
fully transparent keep talking i can
hear you
there it is i can hear you
i i you could have kept you could have
kept talking i've been listening to you
the whole time
he's committed now to the song all right
well
we're cut this part out
no we're not cutting it
it's just
i can hear myself on speaker so i'm just
waiting for that to go away because it's
one of those things where i can hear
myself talk
and i can't put together a coherent
sentence
yeah right now this is literally
yeah yeah i can hear it
i can hear it feeding back
segways so i have i have a i have an
interesting request could we take a data
set being like a bunch of the corridor
casts yes
and then create one
what what the ai considers to be
corridor cast voice
yes i was going to just go around and
get a minute from everyone in the studio
yeah i love that and just i was that was
that's one of the one of the many
experiments to do with this yeah but i
wonder what that would sound like it'd
probably be really weird probably yeah i
am very curious what it sounds like too
i wonder you so like when you do a deep
fake with different data sets
theoretically you could have it so if
you look to the left it looks like one
face and if you if you look to the right
it looks like another face so i'm
wondering if that would be the same for
the audio set where it's like depending
on the words people say in the audio and
that like in the data set
it will sound more like their voice you
know what i'm saying like it'll kind of
average things but it might also make it
so that
on certain types of vowels or you know
sounds that you would make it would
sound yeah more like one person or
another dude i'm really curious about
that like what does the average corridor
crew voice sound like
can we just put crew voice 04 on there
for a minute and just let it go i i
really wonder if if we would find
something interesting in that exp in
that experiment like
we listened to and like oh wait a second
we all kind of sound like this this is
funny yeah it's like you can't i can't
pinpoint who it sounds like it sounds
like everyone or maybe it's like you're
saying it's like like halfway through a
word suddenly it starts sounding like me
when it was sounding like you
yeah i think it's morphs i have that's
my bet it would be like this weird
conception
i mean like
i want to break the program honestly
like i want to see how far we can push
this service so that like when they see
this video they're like oh no
what have you done oh no well i know
with deep fakes there are certain
sentences you can say right that give
you the full
uh data set that you would need all the
vowels and all the shapes oh yeah yeah
we did that for the
deep fake uh prank video that we just
put out exactly it's like basically
there's a bunch of like what are they
called like phonemes and visemes and
whatnot it's like facial shapes that
your face does when it says certain
like words and sounds yeah and so like
oh really i had to do that a whole bunch
for the deep fake training so that the
the deep fake knew what my face would
look like
making different
different faces essentially yeah is
there something like that for audio
where there's like a
a certain set of sentences that you say
in a certain range of emotions to get
everything you need to get like a full
recreation the range of the emotions is
harder to like nail but yeah there's
tons of those
like out there i've seen those and a lot
of the other services of services i've
used like kind of tend to have that
here's like there's like 20 sentences to
say that kind of generally covers
everything i'm like kind of curious to
see if i could like i don't intend to
replace my my voice in like my scale
videos you know where i write out a
script and then i narrate the whole
thing and then i add footage on top of
it that's kind of the order i do things
but part of me is like could i just like
write out the script feed it into that
and just sped out an audio file that's
like flawless the problem is that it's
not gonna have any of the sort of
performances that i always give where
you know sometimes i talk a little
quietly and then i start talking really
loud and excited i don't think those
voice defects can really like just
switch between those pretty quick yeah
that's the thing right now which is like
i i wonder if there's a version out
there that is more like a deep fake
where
you
actually say something and then it
replaces
the vocal performance with a different
voice right yeah versus
this is kind of more it's just text to
speech yeah it's just super advanced
text-to-speech right now
yeah that's not voice fake um
what happens if you i guess it doesn't
matter if you do different languages i
mean does it know or is it kind of only
programmed for english or like what if
what if you did spanish for example i
don't know would it
i i mean i don't know what that
service is like specifically built
around but in theory the language is
irrelevant as long as the words and the
the actual speech are the same you know
it's like i mean you're trained on a
bunch of words
spelled out i know accents would work if
you say everything with an action that's
my question about it it would sound like
you were
the accent would still carry over
that's right i wonder wait can we make
ourselves have accents you just teach
someone to say a certain sentence with
an accent you could just do but you can
do silly voices too you could go like
you could like like use like once upon a
time here's the thing
and then like the ai voice would sound
like that
yeah that's so funny i really like that
idea of of having like silly ai voices
they sound very like convincing overall
you're like this is
it sounds like a but it's still a voice
it's like a silly robot so i i want to
be able to utilize this for brand
integrations where like we punch in the
talking points
and then it gives you back the talking
points
in well in whatever voice you want
really but like
that would make brand integrations way
more efficient
yeah
i know well that's like the joke here
which is if we can do a sponsorship for
this video it's basically that we we
just
paste that in there and then just yeah
create an audio file
yeah and there's there's so much more to
this too it's like you could then like
take a cg character and and do like like
with the blend shapes on the facial
animations and whatnot uh there's i
don't know what the tool is peter was
mentioning it this morning where
basically just write out text and it'll
synthesize the facial animation to say
that text so all there's one service
called replica studios that does that
specifically like that is their
that is their business model which is
hey do you have a bunch of npcs in a
game and don't want to hire 20 voice
actors it's like
just use these ai voices that you can
you know take draw from our library or
maybe train your own or whatever
um and it'll automatically like add that
to a character and then basically yeah
you can create conversation lists and
beat lists and stuff out of it and then
they have plug-ins that allow you to
take those audio files and lip-sync
characters oh wow yeah the lip sync yeah
yeah i wonder if that's functional for a
local zero
i don't know if i think maybe there's
too many like main
dialogue scenes yeah it's just there's
no performance
there's no performance in the stuff so
it's like it's good for like npc
shopkeepers like ella welcome to my
store
you know kind of crime you know
it's like i've seen there is a wolf
outside the city would you like to
chase him you know it's like stop you've
broken the laws
yeah yeah
i'm walking into the table
yeah yeah
it's very much on that level it's like
it could easily replace all the dialogue
in like an rpg from the early 2000s but
we could track
we could track words
spoken words onto
a deep fake of me
onto
a model and then i wouldn't have to
appear in brand integrations ever yeah
didn't you just see that i saw you like
that one video too when today that the
deep fake onto the matey human yeah yeah
because i've been thinking about that
for a while
and someone's finally doing it i just
know it's it's been happening for a
while but you know
you know that's a debate on it made a
human is it tom cruise one yeah dude
this is a great idea it's like the face
looks amazing but the lip sync doesn't
quite work like you still have all the
problems of
i guess you still have to animate the
character fully
it's just all it does is it makes the
the model look more realistic yeah yeah
so you know you still have all your
original issues
aren't there pre aren't there pre-baked
animations though from like mixamo that
you could just like no no we're talking
about face animations like hi i'm happy
hi i'm sad
hi my lips are moving perfectly to the
words i'm saying like those kind of
issues
still apply here the deep fake just
takes it and makes it look nicer
but if you had a model that mimics
spoken word wouldn't it do some of that
well no see that's the thing the problem
is the fidelity you know it's like it'll
get the face
like rendered realistically and it'll
look great as long as you're not talking
the moment you start talking
it's it struggles a little bit because
it's trying to recreate those lips now
that it hasn't been too much of a
problem when we're deep faking uh live
performance because the animation of the
live performance is flawless it's real
and and so the deep fake is helped a lot
by that but the problem is that cg faces
their facial animation is all right for
most of the face except for the lips the
lips is like the hardest thing to
animate realistically and that sort of
like
low fidelity animation of the lips comes
through in the deep fake
because the deep egg is just a mask it's
recreating what it already sees
got it yeah no that makes sense and
that's i mean nonetheless though that is
something i do want to like experiment
with i do think there's like potential
for like doing something there you know
especially with like digi doubles but
doing a talking scene that's that's
challenging man
hey everyone i'm outside here in the
wilderness because what i've realized is
that having a sponsor like today's
sponsor storyblocks as a tool for your
creativity is like being set free it's
like being outside in the natural world
you see if you guys don't know storybox
is the one stop shop for all of your
stock asset needs and we use them all
the time over here at corridor digital
anytime we need something whether it's
high quality 4k b-roll images audio
after effects templates motion graphics
and more we go to story blocks and using
their unlimited all access plan we can
download as much as we need from the
site and use it in whatever we need
whether that's a commercial video a
youtube video anything else it's all
royalty free storybox has a virtually
unlimited library so we never have to
worry about exhausting previous things
that we may have pulled from the site
they're constantly updating and it's a
beautiful thing and it's like being set
free from our indoor bounds we are free
to go anywhere hear the birds chirp do
you hear that crow
thing is totally messing up all of my
audio maybe it's just a stock asset i
don't know so the next time you guys are
in need of a stock asset and you're
sitting in a dark room hacking away at a
computer maybe you're working on an edit
or visual effects you need a little help
i want you to think of the beautiful
outdoors and don't actually go outside
go to storybox.com
corridor cast to get started or just
click the link in the description below
that's storyblocks.com corridor cast the
one-stop shop for all your stock asset
needs
all right time to go
[Music]
for me so earlier
when i was showing this to you ryan i
talked about what my dream was
hmm
my
we've dreamed about this for many months
now
my dream is
to
create a true virtual influencer
where oh i love it so much like his own
profile there's no one writing a script
and there's no one saying the words that
was one of the everything all the
content is a hundred percent ai
generated content like
an ai generates the script we take that
script and we feed it into the ai voice
and the ai voice speaks all the dialogue
and then all we do is just plug that
into a little script we're making that
lip syncs the virtual character
to say
whatever the ai wanted it to say
and now suddenly we have an we have like
it's it's the button i'm calling it the
button you hit a button and content
happens
it's just like you like content and then
some rand
completely unspoken sentence
is said by this virtual character so
your dream is to basically do this
we can do this no we are
right we are there
as of like basically right now it's
taken a while precipice so so here's the
thing like
we we talked about this we talked about
peter and myself were like dude we got
to do this right now we don't want to do
the virtual tick talker
um yes and needs to happen and like
right now with the tools all the mocap
i've done all the face animation i've
done
and all that stuff all the unreal stuff
is fine it has finally converged now
with this ai technology um
and
it's pretty it's pretty amazing so yeah
we have to stop it we have to stop
everything and then do this it's all
leading to the button and then basically
we make a tick-tock account or something
and then just like randomly like five
times a day just like yeah random ai
tick tocks are uploaded but we haven't
actually have it actually automated so
you click a button on your computer and
then everything else is formatted and it
immediately posts i really yeah so there
will be some like maybe some macros or
some things we have to do as well
but uh it's it's we're
so close
like i mean right now we don't quite
have we're not quite at the button level
it's it's like we would have to we could
like it's is it's still as easy as
generating like 10 voice clips and then
you slap him in unreal and he hit play
and then
it goes from there
but uh right now connecting a voice api
so that way like
the
yeah that's that that's where the
the missing link is right now which is
like in unreal is basically voice api is
feeding it the dialogue it needs
um because yeah right now we would still
have to manually create audio files and
drop them in to unreal can you this that
purpose yeah can you do something
similar with ai scripts where you feed
it certain source material and it can
generate a script in the same vein yeah
so you could give it just all the
writings of the greatest minds in
history and create this little ai
influencer who comes up with its own
gems
it could be the wisest creation dude he
made a wrap about candles this morning
yeah he wanted me to do a candle wrap
and it was like kind of it would fell
into the cadence of a rap song it didn't
quite rhyme perfectly but
it had the right people it was trying
and then he also made a rap about peter
and i but here's the thing it's like
it's forget the greatest minds you know
for a moment
like the crazy thing with ai script
writing is that you can give it a format
so if let's say okay let's say you want
a virtual influencer like what do we
need well we need to pair animations
we need to pair like what are we gonna
look at where is it where is the virtual
character going to be where what are
they doing all that kind of stuff so
in your ai script you can train it to
basically
follow the guidelines you set for it
such as the ai will the iai script will
say things like the character will be
doing this in this location and will be
speaking with this pitch of voice
and then that way when you feed that
uh into unreal
uh what happens is that it can we can
parse that text file that the ai script
is reading and then it can go okay oh
dancing and it sees the word dancing in
the script and then parses that which
funnels it through a blueprint where
then it gives it a dancing animation too
so
holy smokes there's a lot of yeah so
basically like the the ai itself
can create like
effectively a script that unreal uses
to make decisions on what you see
dude there's such a crazy dichotomy
going on right now here at corridor
because it's like
we're talking about all this crazy like
press a button and content happens i did
it all that stuff
the others like what jordan and i are
working on this week is we're basically
doing another one of those like vfx
historical deep dives into like a really
uh like
big vfx like history moment from young
sherlock holmes there's a cg character
called the stained glass man and we did
a bunch of research and looked into that
today and we're gonna try to like
recreate it using modern tools and
whatnot but like this is like a 38 year
old vfx shot
and it's like
they invented stuff like
character rigs camera match moving
depth of field depth of field rendering
like all these stuff that like they
invented to do these like nine shots 38
years ago and so we're like doing this
video about that and sam's over here
being like i synthesized voice and
characters and hit a button and
oh man
god the legal implications of this i
want to talk about the the stained glass
man but let's but let's finish this
conversation about this ai voice the ai
stuff honestly kind of makes me a little
uncomfortable like not gonna lie because
like we already have all of the
information to do like a very good deep
fake of me
yeah like on anyone and so that's like a
little concerning because
i like not that this will happen but
like in theory if we also do a voice
thing too we can now make it so that you
can make me do anything you want against
my will well that's the thing that's up
for the button to decide so this is
so the funny the funny thing is so you
know how sometimes you're on a website
or you have an application and they show
you the terms of service
and you click agree or sometimes if it's
a serious one you type your name as a
digital signature when you start using
these services
your digital signature is an audio
recording of you consenting like in
order for me to train these data sets i
have to
pull my microphone up to my face while
i'm in the browser and click record and
say
i sam consent to my voice being used for
part of this data set knowing that it
will be able to be recreated by this ai
algorithm in any way shape or form and
so then i hit stop recording and i say
accept and then i send it
wow wow like it's it's really intense
like i'm like i'm like whoa this is this
is the most futuristic
consent i've ever given
because that kind of like that that
works
because you do replicate you
because it's like you're giving this
other company this other service all of
your data for your voice now granted all
of the data is basically out there
already because
we have said a lot of stuff on the
internet you know it's like someone can
easily go through and make a very high
fidelity deep fake of our faces and
voices just purely from pulling from
corridor youtube channels easy
easy like all the stuff we've been
talking about on podcasts and all the
crew videos all the vfx artists react
there's like so much
just stuff out there to to pull from
like that's why we saw some of the
earliest voice deep fakes being from joe
rogan because he's got like a thousand
episodes like hundreds of hours of just
him talking right yeah i mean sam said
what 15 minutes to get something this
morning yeah that's pretty 15 minutes of
audio yeah imagine the hours and hours
and hours and hours you could do
something crazy dude yeah and we're not
that far away from being able to just do
a performance and have someone else's
voice plastered onto that performance
okay so jake's thinking okay
so there's a couple things i want to hit
here one is the legal implications but
first and foremost i was i was going
through
old videos um because i'm coming up with
i'm repackaging our library to like be
so that we can have like new shows on
the website so it's like here's all of
our archery videos you know like here's
all of our we've done a lot vlogs about
drones you know
yeah
but right now it's like where are those
and how do you find them it's like a
total mystery
um so i found a video from 2016 wren
where you and nico and brandon are
talking about
snapchat filters oh yeah and
yeah and you guys are talking about
something
very similar to this but it was sort of
before the technology you were like
predicting basically where technology
was gonna go uh-huh and one of the
theories that you guys were talking
about was how in in like
well in in media or in news but kind of
in any medium
people won't need makeup artists anymore
because they'll be able to have like a
such a high fidelity like up resin of
their face
that it it won't be
necessary now obviously you have all
these tracking issues and all this
lighting issues and all this other stuff
too but like
that as well as the idea that like you
could put obama's face on anybody
in because we were talking about the
googly eyes video
kind of in the context of that and then
we were saying how like actually we're
not that far away from
being able to put like anybody's face on
anybody
i mean we've been doing that you know
like i know and we've been doing that
like but it's like crazy that it's
it's even more
it's even more approachable now than it
was
then and now brandon's really good at
like predicting the future in my opinion
he's very insightful about some of that
really like sort of like esoteric
like tech stuff
he's kind of he's he's got like the
eccentric like you know
creator thing going on like he's been
he's he's there's a couple things he's
been wrong about thankfully but he's
been writing about that stuff
yeah i know they're stressful zero's
going hard on a bunch of ai driven stuff
too for their new game it's really cool
yeah
yeah
um so but anyway that brings me to
the legal implications of this
because like
what
does it mean say just let's just think
about this hypothetically okay we've got
the the content button
you click the button
and content comes out the other side
it's posted on tick tock
you
theoretically
have no control
over what it posts i mean obviously you
have control of the account
but like i mean we could
what if it like
what if it like slanders somebody yeah
true or like
is it is it is it illegal or does it
have to be a human or like whose
response it brings up fascinating legal
questions in this particular situation
if any of those
uh eventualities
come from eventualities
um
all that happens is that we get banned
from using these services
uh so then the that's where it stops so
we would have to make sure we actually
approve and reject that kind of crap i
mean do you remember
like true
like that's why that's why this ai stuff
is still behind closed doors at the
moment because
they people understand that
it can do that you know
very frequently it talks about the
n-word
you know and yeah right i mean nazis
specifically mm-hmm you know
these many of these text-based ais
frequently circle back to hitler um
because there's just so much writing
about hitler in world war ii that's it's
just impossible for it to like
completely avoid the subject since it's
trained on so much data yeah so do you
guys remember the the ai that microsoft
made they made a whole twitter account i
was able to like write and post tweets
autonomously based off of just training
from twitter and very quickly it started
getting dark yeah it started like i
forgot some of the specifics but it
started like no i remember that
flandering it was like it took a day for
it to basically say hitler wasn't that
bad
i think i'm pretty sure that was
specifically very quickly like developed
into like just like a [ __ ] posting meme
account exactly it was just like i was
like
delete
yeah see that's what i'm saying okay
everyone
it's like does that say more about the
ai or humanity humanity
about humanity because once again these
ais are not original they're just
compilations of the data sets some of
the most advanced compilations but
compilations nonetheless
yeah it's not coming up with anything
original
there's gonna be so
so this is my fear as a lawyer like
there's gonna be so many things that are
gonna be happening
over the next
well
maybe at some point like the onslaught
of
new developments
into like the digital medium
in general will sort of like slow down
but maybe not either way we're about 25
years in or so
from like real
you know like
what are we talking like like actively
using digital mediums for like all
different types of things like you know
you remember like early internet days
and it was like the internet was still
this sort of separate thing
well now we're like 25 years until like
no this is like in our lives and it's on
our phones and it's you know we're
communicating through it right now
and and all that stuff
and i my fear like and i know this is
already happening but the law is not
going to be able to keep up with this so
funny fun fact it's not going to be able
to the law keeping up with ai
what if i presented a new idea to you
an ai
an ai that helps you keep up with it
yes so
let me give you a pitch
one of the biggest uses for ai
and when it comes to the text-based
world is the idea that you can feed this
ai a multi-page document
and it's able to go through it
understand the meaning of the document
understand the connections between the
words and summarize it
you can that like that is one of the
main features that we see here is when
it comes to like ai writers and ai blogs
and ai stuff basically one of one of the
main features that have been commonly
focused on is this concept of summary so
you can feed it an ai a huge wikipedia
document and then it can spit out
a rather you know it's it's not flawless
right now but it's an effective summary
of the data that's within it so rather
than having to read every word you you
get basically the gist of it so that'd
be really useful in many different areas
you have to train the data set though on
like the specific
field exactly exactly so what i imagine
is it's this idea that like it's kind of
creepy and it's the idea of like what if
to write a law
right when you write a law you want to
be specific you want to be super super
specific
with like your language and the specific
words you use so that way it's very
clear but what if it was let's let's
just say
it went in reverse where it's like i
want a law that bans
all bananas dude okay finally and so
what if we just did that and now now
it's now we're 10 years this is 2032
and everyone's a piece of [ __ ] and we
type
and some stupid politician writes i want
to ban bananas and then he says convert
to a law
and then it spits out this like massive
20-page thing that says exactly how
bananas would ever be banned from
everything in society ever
and he's not going to read the whole
thing
he's never going to read the whole thing
he's going to submit it and then when
people look at this thing they're like
what is this thing and they feed them
they just all they do is they feed that
back to an ai to re-summarize it for
them
and then
and now they're going like okay so so
this has to do with bananas he doesn't
want bananas in these places okay all
right so this is about banning bananas
you know and then then they argue it's
like do we ban bananas or not and
they're they're arguing about the core
foundation of the law but no one's
actually ever reading the text that
would go into effect or better yet you
could just say no and have the ai draft
an argument
yeah that's almost already happening
with a lot of stuff that comes through
congress right now it's like that's the
crazy thing i wouldn't be obsessed at
least it's still being written by humans
i wouldn't be surprised if like
that's happening right now where people
are submitting like
legal documents that they that a human
didn't write
um
yeah well have you maybe like edited you
know maybe maybe seeing this the stacks
of some of these quote unquote bills
that
like they're you know
yeah
they'll be
9 000 page documents
and they'll be changing it and
resubmitting it
within eight hours of voting on it it's
like
at what at what point is that just so
wholly i mean this is something that ai
could seriously help with first of all
totally it could but it could yeah
it could also be getting
you could also be in a situation like
what you're saying where it's like guy
hits button
and then everyone interprets and then
more ai interprets that
yeah
you hit a button to make an ai
interpretation and then everyone hits a
button to reinterpret the ai back to it
like a summary and then hit another
button to rebuttal it with something and
then that gets summarized and rebuttaled
again and it's like it's just people
just like letting ais have a field day
it goes to a fundamental question when
it comes to law which is like can it
can it even be applicable
if it's not from
a human and if it's not from more
specifically like where the sovereignty
of human
community like exists there's this
concept in law which is like
a law is only
functional if it if it's the source from
where it originates is is from like the
sovereign
and where the sovereign is and who the
sovereign is changes over time and
different legal structures but
in in america we say the sovereignty
exists within the people and so if the
law doesn't come from the people if it's
not directly
transmutable back to the people it
cannot apply okay and i agree i
personally agree and it's funny because
today or maybe yesterday but very
recently uh someone tried to
uh basically copyright
um some ai art oh i saw that
and the the court saw it and they looked
at it and they're like nope
we're that's not under that's you're not
we're not like allowing you
to like claim copyright over this
because
uh uh an ai made it i know yeah i
thought there was a i wasn't sure if now
granted i didn't read into this at all
but like i wasn't sure if it was you
cannot copyright ai generated artwork or
ai can't
copyright
its own stuff like i wasn't sure where
like this sort of it ended up kind of
being both where legal theory is
following kind of what
we were just saying which is that
ai is not capable of creating a modicum
of creativity which is the minimum
standard
from which copyright
has to exist it has to be a modicum of
creativity
in a tangible form yeah and that comes
full circle back to what we're saying
which is this this compilation yeah
nothing original right there's
technically nothing original going on
but there's still it's still i think you
can still argue that like there's an
artist behind it you know like there's a
it's a tool and the artist is using that
tool to craft something yeah but that
speaks that's like saying i sold you a
hammer and
every nail you hit with it becomes mine
you know you can you can definitely make
that argument like that's that's the
thing is like that's what i was saying
about i don't think the law is in any
way shape or form like ready okay or
this
because that's a that's honestly not a
bad argument it's just not something
that's ever been
encountered before either right so you
could say like no the artist is using ai
as a tool to create
a modicum of creativity
and therefore copyrightable
but given that the entire precedent the
the thousands of years of like
legal precedent in terms of what is art
and how can it be owned and how can it
be like protected
it's all based on it coming from a human
being so so sorry just to recap the
copyright office rejected a request to
let an ai copyright a work of art
so okay so okay so that being said
that's different too because it's not a
legally um
recognized
person
which is good because ai's have the
ability to just like generate millions
of things and if it's also able to
copyright millions of things instantly
it's going to be a big problem real
quick
yeah it has to be legally it has to be a
legally
identifiable person
copyright and that's what i'm saying
about the laws and like where the laws
come from and like how they apply like
that's that's a fundamental concept is
that our laws to copyright something if
you're going to do that it has to be
from a person because only human beings
can carry that ability yeah so with us
in reading deeper about the ruling and
stuff basically it does transfer over to
other
other forms of air
ai produced stuff because basically the
ai can't copyright it which is great
thank god
or else we would all die
but secondly copyright dead if you have
an a ai art generator
and it makes you a piece of art or
something
it's still not
copyrightable until it's like actually
like modified or done you have to do
something
but like if an ai spits something out
that itself
isn't
eligible interesting okay that is
interesting
and what about like generative art you
know like those uh
like you know the the board ape yacht
club thing or like where they literally
have like 10 000 unique uh images i'm
not saying that any of that stuff is
like good or bad i'm just saying it's
like it's not quite ai generated but
it's it is driven through like a uh
an algorithm of some like you have
different versions of the hat different
versions of the face different outfits
different but all expressions
that we're seeing were created by a
person they yeah yeah but then they're
all
algorithmically combined sure but that's
different it's this the image itself
wasn't generated generated by it all
you'd have to do by the way
if you had an ai image that was wholly
generated by ai all you'd have to do is
like like you said add a signature
smear it change it
to a filter tiniest yeah the tiniest way
such that now it is copyrightable by a
human
um but it's weird which it's it's a
really weird time where like we are
going to be running into this issue
of whether or not something is even
legally
possible within the construct of our
league of our legalities to begin with
all the time over the next like 50 years
dude i'm going to bed in like 30 years
or so there's going to be a giant trial
because we finally made an ai that's
able to think for itself well enough to
argue that it deserves more rights you
know it's like you know classic sci-fi
bicentennial man yeah bicentennial man
you know it's like
by centennial man was that
[Laughter]
the question of sentience it will
will matter it's going to be a big deal
probably in like 30 years i love making
digital art but this scares me so much
that i just hope that by the time any of
this stuff happens i'm like a hermit um
like you're already in the woods i'm
gonna enjoy it while it's good and then
once it gets kind of loopy i'm like all
right
i'm going off the grid and it feels like
it's going to get loopy there's no
avoiding it and it kind of just feels
like you know with the law situation
kind of all of it you need ai to counter
ai in any way there's no real weight
over there is
that's true that's very true and that's
a good thing that like that we all need
to be aware so it's like the matrix
resurrections the lessons we learned
from maestro's resurrections
upon the robots for survival but the
robots are reliant upon us you know like
this sort of mutually assured
destruction
well like you know you know this raises
an interesting point here where you know
let's say okay you're a scientist
philanthropist billionaire or whatever
and you're saying we ought to watch out
for ai you know we hear that a lot okay
yeah and like this conversation is like
giving me a new perspective on that
where previously i was kind of more just
simply thinking about it under the idea
of
like an agi like a conscious
general intelligence or a gi you know
like yeah so so it's like all right
here's a here's a thinking computer that
wants to do things like how do we handle
this new type of thought
whereas like
before we even get there we still have
to deal with this idea of
people creating ais that completely
disrupt
like
life as we know it effectively whereas
you know an ai that tries to copyright
or trademark like four billion things
that it generates
or um you know
some news sites being like all right hey
no human writers anymore so technically
no one's reading what's going out there
and it's being sent to people um or an
ai that buys all the ps5s an ai that
buys the ps5 or stop it i want one dude
i'm literally signing up for like
freaking walmart plus right now just so
i can get the drop on thursday desperate
times
yeah there's i don't know
all kinds of of like
functional
supply chain
legal yeah all of these are gonna be
happening before before we have like the
ai on trial you know yeah before there's
the robot guy there who's saying i am a
man
i am a man
before we get there we need to like do
the laws of saying like these are the
things you can't use ai for because
like it's very manipulative and it
exploits everyone's trust and
i guess i guess yeah trust in our
systems i think i mean that's the world
of the biggest that's the world of dune
yeah no like dune takes place in a
post-ai world they had a whole war
between like humanity and ai and
computers and all that stuff and that's
why no one in
in the dune universe like uses computers
oh yeah you're right then that's they
just smoke crack
it's
our only choice
[Laughter]
basically you know but it's like that's
yeah you're right no you're right that's
crazy though
we should get on top of this ai stuff
y'all
one thing though that it brings to mind
is i i think
you're right there's a huge threat there
but also i think
we also have a tendency with this stuff
to to really like let it run run rampant
in our imagination
you know and we also have to remember
like humans are pretty
like we like our routines
you know we sort of like things kind of
like as is
for the most part
you know it and we're willing to accept
like significant levels of suffering
as long as it's not like
a change
to our own
you know concept of reality and things
like that and so
that that honestly can work to our
advantage i think a little bit with some
of this stuff like just just keeping in
mind like
people aren't going to be like
that ambitious to
convert like for example
the maida verse
like people aren't eager to convert to
that you know i'm so out of the loop is
the maida verse like a a thing right now
like vr chat when when mark zuckerberg
she said hey i'm making them made a
verse
they they actually released something
i believe so yeah because i've seen like
no screenshots i've seen no videos of it
they didn't release
anything like big you know it's not like
they're like all right the metaverse is
here and then they just like open the
floodgates to
by oh what's the author's name he wrote
snow crash 70s
neal stevenson yeah i'm pretty sure he's
the one who coined that term metaverse i
think he coined cyberpunk but think
about think about that and probably made
a verse
vr is the best example of this
because when when things got real hot
with vr in like 2015
everyone was saying that by this time
people are going to be working in their
headsets
and you know like
living what's happening now though
yeah but one of my best friends
literally works in a headset
i know ren but you also have to realize
like you know some pretty eccentric
people like you're not exactly
considered like the a greatest data set
to like analyze this for like the whole
of humanity i would be surprised you
know people who give you jet packs
but i know i know what you're saying
well it's it's not it's not the complete
mass appeal that people thought it would
be
it's not anywhere near what some of the
people that were super hyped on like the
venture capital money and the
possibilities of it all
it's not anywhere near that i mean
granted there's some people using it for
for different things obviously it's also
just so early days still like yeah but
if anything about code has taught me
it's like dude that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
working from home like
sorry jake but you know oh it's fine
dude dude [ __ ] working for one sucks
ass tear it up dude
i've gotten so used to it now man it's
so much more fun coming here and
chilling with you guys in person no for
sure been [ __ ] zooming
i have
when i when it is the middle of the work
day at the studio i
enjoy being at the studio oh yeah more
than more than i do working out of my
home studio
yeah yeah yeah that's what i'm saying
it's like man and so you give some
people a headset and they're like hey
this is your new life
i mean that's i mean that is absolutely
going to be more and more of a thing
over the next decade i know it's like
we're still so early days i know you're
right as real estate prices and rent
keep skyrocketing people will eventually
just go you know what let's this 15 by
15 foot room works
yeah because it's just big enough to set
my guardian boundaries on my headset and
yeah that's so true
what's nuts you're like you're right i
just i don't know if it's going to be as
rampant as anybody
people like the real world is my point
right people people like the realities
and alternate realities and those are
fun
but like people also like
the real world generally
absolutely i mean i'm a 100 believer in
that i love the real world i love going
out into the wilderness i love going on
one-wheel rides i love everything about
reality ten out of ten yeah yeah
yeah and nine nine sure but all what i'm
getting at is like it's like all the
dumb stuff like all right you know
they've already had bots on wall street
for you know decades at this point you
know like what's the v3 v4 of that at
this point you know are we it's probably
once again i'm talking about stuff that
there's people doing this right now
you know but it's that kind of stuff too
of of of like super high level ai
manipulation that you know people don't
find out about until something goes
horribly wrong with it basically
that's going to happen you know like ai
financial market manipulation
and you know like we'll even as a you
know we're we are in
i i've seen multiple
posts on reddit that are on the front
page basically uh that are either like
algorithm based or ai written articles
like and people ingest them and then you
like you read it and you're like you
start checking out you're like this is
[ __ ] like this is not a real person
writing this and in the comments like
it's like only still like the second or
third comment of someone saying hey
anyone notice something fishy with the
way this is written you know like it's
it's out there it's happening
yeah so
yeah
no we get emails like that all the time
of people
saying like we wanna
it's it's these weird a.i written
we want to collaborate with you
emails you know like christian knows
what i'm talking about oh i know exactly
what you're talking about every email
starts like that we were like the moment
i see an email thread that was saying
hey hello influencer hey we want to go
influencers
yeah hey let's let's collaborate on
something it's like what
like what do you even do what is this
you're a robot
but the really malicious side of that is
when they include like a little image
and like a tiny little like one pixel by
one pixel image that's stored on their
server and they know when that image
gets loaded so they know if you've read
the email yeah that's really silly
that's right dude emojis in subject
lines um
[Laughter]
dangerous man that's one of the greatest
threats to our future professional
emojis and subject lines is definitely a
great threat to him dude we can now put
a big away that mess freaking your real
flow dude yeah
but you say you could put emojis and
urls i think so i saw some some news
about like uh
i want to make a website like like sam
gorski dot like crying
[Music]
crying pumpkin
crying
smelly turd
oh man
that's funny
but there's also all the great ai things
that we get to do as i was saying like
you know this is this cool fun future
where we get to summarize legal
documents
and parse them
we're going to actually that would be
really useful it would be like the 9 000
pages you see in congress you're like i
want to know what those laws actually i
want to know what's actually in there so
you just like have that parsed for you
and summarized and you're like oh and
bananas right they just want to fan
bananas
like the real
uh trick there would be like to identify
all of like the the hidden
things that you know you can hide in a
lot like oh yeah here's like a little
line and by the way um pineapples are
half off
it's like hidden in that it's like
you're just hoping that someone will
just like glance over it not really data
set if the data set is trained on the
right
or if the if if the summary ai is
trained on the right data set though it
would it would catch that or it would
point it out as being not legally
binding
yeah it would be like no this is that
nothing's ever written this way
therefore like this language is
suspect to not being applicable or you
know it would it would
yeah but this is something that like
real
legal institutions would have to
guide because without it it would
be super dangerous first of all and then
it would probably be wrong second of all
yeah i mean it just feels like as fast
as ai is developing in like the deep
fake side of things there's the counter
ai developing as well in terms of
identifying deep fakes
you know it feels like they'll go with a
parallel to where they'll kind of
combat each other and we're getting
smarter when it comes to the stuff just
as the general public we're becoming
more aware of these things and more able
to point them out when it's uncanny
valley or there's a slight problem i
mean yeah but you're totally right
though it's like that adversarial aspect
of this is like as old as time it's like
you get hackers but then you also get
like security experts right you like
toughen up security and then the hackers
get better to be able to hack that
security and they get better at
defending themselves and whatnot and
it's like we're constantly seeing that
sort of back and forth so like in the
law thing it's like language would then
change to be able to circumvent some of
these you know ais that are only trained
on specific things well if you get some
new data that's not in that data set yet
well then it's not ready for it unless
it's like specifically trained to be
like adaptable but i mean i don't know
this is all stuff i don't really know
you know it's like
no you i mean you're right you think
about the history of human technology
and anytime something is being used
adversarially
there's another
sort of equally powerful
tool that comes along that
counterbalances the first thing i mean
this is especially true with weapons
technology
but yeah many other technologies as well
but man what's gonna be super cool is um
there this is the thing that's being
worked on right now but it's the idea of
taking
like casual language and converting it
to code for programs oh so when you want
to make a script or something or a
blueprint or you know
c-plus make it spin you basically say uh
you literally just type spawn four cubes
100 units apart
apply physics to three of them make this
one red and then uh four seconds in i
want them to all bounce into the air
with one meter per second velocity you
know and then it like the map would load
and you know like it can that's what i'm
excited okay that's officially the most
exciting thing you have to take that
kind of language
so cool and script that for you because
it's trained on you know all the code
and understands what you're trying to
accomplish
i mean coding is a language so it's like
it's it's kind of similar to just like a
translation right exactly exactly
wow that's very cool yeah can i give you
a stretch goal on your button idea
button
don't make a button that makes content
make a button that makes buttons that
make content
because then you're one step removed
legally as well and no one can shut you
down
across the globe i don't think that
really matters
like whatever happens like
like i'm hitting a button and whatever
happens next yeah yeah yeah i don't know
my button
is
just made buttons and the buttons didn't
do anything it's like literally the
computer like yeah that's a funny thing
you could do where it's like hey i'm
going to base the decision making off of
someone else's decisions yeah so like uh
i don't know like you may be taking some
algorithm like hey i'm gonna make it
reddit's fault so each time something
goes to the front page of reddit that uh
has the word like
oc in it or something like that yeah my
digital button becomes pressed and then
something happens and i'm like
why didn't you post that
nothing it wouldn't have said like
hitler did nothing wrong
if you didn't post this on reddit yeah
it's one step removed it just feels like
the logical
it's like hey
i didn't say it
i didn't i didn't prompt it it's a
possibility it was going to happen but
i'm just your humble text-to-speech
programmer over here i don't know okay
i mean this tick-tock thing dances too
but you know
you don't want to see the dance
it's going to be wise all this stuff is
evolving so much more rapidly than
anyone realizes that's what yeah i keep
coming back to well it's an exponential
curve isn't it exactly yeah
and you never know where the top of the
curve is when you're on it you look at
you know i saw just the other day a
comparison of the new uh
horizon forbidden west forbidden west
yeah you know graphics compared to one
two three i want to get a ps5 legit 100
and you're talking about 20 30 years
gap and such a huge leap
in what is possible graphically and you
think about that but also when there's
trillions and trillions of dollars on
the line when it's the greatest minds
putting their minds towards ai
development and then the ai further
developing itself exponentially
and that on top of that on top of that
you lose track so fast i'm sure we
already have to some degree because elon
musk is terrified of it isn't he well i
mean i don't know if he's terrified
but like he's he's come out and said
that like it's like
you know
summoning a demon and i think is how he
calls this like
and and he specifically follows that up
yeah they're pretty sure they can
control the demon they're pretty sure
i feel like it's more like kind of what
i was talking about earlier which is
it's less about like this the robot on
trial yeah so to speak but this concept
of
these the like algorithms that are
operating independently and at a super
fast rate where they can really screw
things up yeah
yeah that that is that is a serious
thing that i don't think anyone's
considering at least not nearly to the
extent that we should be but like
what's to say that there can't be some
series of you know
like economic
algorithms that are looking for
say you know gaps in the in the free
market and
they they're like guess what
we just noticed that there's a
shortage on this good
and if we buy
all of the available units on the market
we will be able to
you know
make a profit and this is something that
like you know happened to the ps5
you know like a capital like a capital
management firm that's managing you know
trillions and trillions of dollars like
say like blackrock or something could
easily
come up with something like this that's
like oh so it it bought all the toilet
paper
you know or it bought all the it bought
all name name name a widget that's a
consumable good
and it bought all of them and now
they're not available for like the next
six months because like
nobody globally is prepared for that and
there's no way that we don't have
you know it's just that those types of
weird things are gonna happen
i don't know if they're gonna happen at
that scale but like
you know
it's there's going to be some hey
there's a shortage of this right now
because this ai thing did that or yeah i
don't know it's yeah
it's hard to it's hard to predict
exactly the manifestation but given
given what we're seeing
it's it's kind of
how can you say
you know that something like that
won't be happening
yeah that live deep state thing i mean
that's so nuts
that that's already here
granted it's been improved since then
but like i only heard about this like a
couple months ago and that's stuff
that's not behind closed doors like
you've seen those those research papers
or those videos of the stuff that
they're working on
uh you know where you're like i saw one
on two minute papers where you you type
something in and they will say it and
their mouth will say it and their voice
will say it wow and you'd literally
change yeah
look at that and
it's crazy that that's already a thing
where i can take a video of you around
and i can
change what you say
to you know give i think their example
was giving a movie you know he says it
was a d i give this movie a d and he
changed it to saying i give this movie
an a plus and your voice says a plus it
sounds just like your voice and your
mouth changes to say a plus yeah
everyone's going to believe that video
yeah right yeah once that gets out from
behind close that's a perfect example
yeah that's a perfect example
because that you know somebody like elon
musk brought down tesla's stock by
having a hit of weed
on a podcast that was goofy
and you know like think about
and then he got fined by the sec for
saying hey we're looking for investors
or whatever he said
like he said we're going to take the
company private
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
that's kind of kind of a thing you can't
say yeah um
yeah
but like yeah you could you could say
that you could you could you could have
a situation where somebody says
something they didn't say and that has
enough of a market effect at least in a
short term
that's that's why i do have hope i mean
i mean that's a problem with media right
now if you [ __ ] believe that and you
watch that video of someone doing
something wacky and it's coming from
not the primary source of where it
should come from
then you're you're you're an idiot but
that's literally happening right now in
the media like like okay until they form
their own narrative and currently cnn
hasn't aired a deep fake of something
and said it was real thankfully okay and
when we talk about this podcast stuff
with elon musk it's like where well
where did you see him smoke the joint
well it was on the source of the podcast
itself it wasn't a isolated clip that
was reposted
so that's true you make a fair point
salmon and there could be combative
technology to help that but yeah
i guess what i'm getting at is that any
corrective measures don't matter you
know like an article can
write something and it could blow up be
sensational and all that stuff and then
like it comes out oh this isn't actually
real and they make a
correction but not in the article but no
one ever sees the corrections i think
that's ever happened one of the closest
things that i even remember is like back
in the trump days uh oh thank god back
in the day there was like a clip of
nancy pelosi that someone just like all
they did was like slow it down a little
bit so it sounded like her speech was
slurred and then they posted to facebook
and a bunch of [ __ ] morons thought it
was real
and
why well it's because they didn't think
about what they were watching it was
just a dumb clip they're stupid and also
they like once again they didn't see it
at the original source it wasn't it it
didn't come like they did not critically
think about what they were looking at
they looked at them they literally
looked at a meme
and thought it was real you know it's
like it's like it's like seeing the
twitter's the onions twitter and then
angrily typing something about no
that's not re this is this is bs or i
can't believe
blah blah blah it's like you're
literally
replying to the onion you know it's like
100 percent do that i guess i mean i
think it's human nature to take stuff at
face value
yeah that's that's my point too and like
you also have to consider like how close
you are to this stuff sam like i'm not
saying you're wrong like that you're
there's it's if with a little critical
thinking it's very the
the veil of falsity comes comes down
really quickly oh yeah but we're also so
close to this stuff by and large in
terms of like most people's everyday
lives
that we see things about it that
we consider to be like second nature i
mean that's why the debunking show i
agree i agree works so well is because
we're like well no look at this have you
thought about this and most people
that stuff is not second nature
so that's also something to keep in mind
i guess well you know you know that's a
very good point and it kind of circles
back to our earlier podcasts in the last
few podcasts here
so we're on a good one i think we're on
a good one we if you if you wanna if you
wanna yeah
we're not gonna talk too much more about
that particular subject because i think
we exhausted that what that means which
is all right let's say you don't have
critical thinking skills so what
platform are you looking at this
information on and is it their fault or
not
so
go see quarter cast 118.
that was like 126. 126.
[Laughter]
well i guess we didn't get a chance to
talk about the uh character first cg
character but i mean we just started
doing it today i'm literally wearing the
same stuff that don't worry like
we're not deep into that like literally
we filmed the intro kind of breaking
down stuff and like that's it you'll
know plenty you have plenty to talk
about
in the future on that um yeah all right
are you guys ready
all right
sorry for calling you an idiot if you
believed anything that i was saying but
also you know
[Music]
i mean we've all fallen victim to that
at some point you yourself fell for that
one bear chase video you said in the
debunking video like oh i saw that and
just like huh cool yeah but it wasn't
like you know it wasn't important
we fell victim to this in in in uh
bollywood oh my god yeah i thought i
thought
it was coming back i was so excited to
do it turns out the return of judea it
was a lie it was all just nobody lost i
didn't eventually realize it was fake
yeah i didn't come away with that
telling everyone hey judo is
[Laughter]
[Music]
that'd be amazing
thanks for listening everyone
if disney made it there'd be a plushie
of it for sure this this whole podcast
was about
the future
fun stuff
all right
i'm gonna feed them the scripts for the
first chris movies and give them a chris
4 script yes yes please oh my god yes
and then have your voice narrate the
whole screen oh my god ai voice narrate
the whole thing
needs to happen yeah
three letters two
one